welcome everyone and thank you for
joining us for today's track on stories
and lessons of the past it's my pleasure
to introduce to you dr. Colleen craft
dr. Kraft is an associate professor of
pathology and Laboratory Medicine at
Emory University School of Medicine
she's a member of the leadership group
for the serious communicable diseases
unit at Emory University Hospital in
Atlanta Georgia she was also one of the
physicians in the care of patients with
the Ebola virus disease and Lassa fever
from 2014 to 2016 for a complete
biography of our speaker please visit
the biography tab at the top of your
screen dr. Kraft keynote presentation is
titled Ebola virus disease 2019 and
beyond my name is Susie Valdez and I'll
be your moderator for today's event
we're delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by
elaborate elaborate is the leading
scientific social networking website and
producer of educational virtual events
and webinars before we begin I want to
remind you that this event is
interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want during the
presentation simply click on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen and type your questions into
the drop-down box our speaker will
respond to your questions via email
following a presentation if you have any
trouble seeing or hearing this
presentation simply click on the ask a
question box and let us know you're
having a problem this presentation is
educational and thus offers continuing
education credits so we click on the
continuing education credits tab located
at the top right corner of your
presentation window and follow the
process to obtain those credits without
further ado please join me in welcoming
dr. Kraft I will now turn the
presentation over to her welcome dr.
Pratt thank you it's my pleasure today
to talk to you about the lesson that we
learned during the care of patients with
Ebola virus disease in the United States
specifically at Emory house
as you can see in my first slide I have
a have a few circles that go across the
top of the slide I always do the one on
the right that's sort of you only see a
quarter of as being that large outbreak
that we had in 2014 in West Africa and
the countries of Liberia Guinea and
Sierra Leone followed by that was sort
of a smaller outbreak as I've indicated
with this grey dot and that was also an
outbreak that concurrently happened
during 2016 at the same time as the
large outbreak we've also had an
additional outbreak that I've indicated
with the yellow dot in the Democratic
Republic of the Congo earlier in 2018
that had a few few cases and was
controlled but she should all know that
currently in 2019 there's an enlarging
outbreak that's occurring in the
Democratic Republic of the Congo as we
speak at this time of the recording we
have over 1,100 cases and fatality rate
that is in between 30 to 50 percent
depending on the location so we should
care about Ebola virus disease today it
is something that's occurring overseas
and certainly has implications for
global travel and also preparedness
around the United States and elsewhere
so I always begin my talks about Ebola
virus disease asking that question is it
still relevant and as I've already
discussed we're already in an outbreak
that is happening from since since late
2018 this has been happening in the
North Kivu province of the Democratic
Republic of Congo
and while on this slide it says there's
been a total of 996 cases we do know
that it's already grown to over a
thousand cases you can see here a map of
the region that's been affected with
Ebola virus disease in the Democratic
Republic of the Congo the main takeaway
from this is this this area of the
Democratic Republic of the Congo orders
other African nations and so this also
just stands ready to go over into other
nations which will make this outbreak
more complicated so we continue to
monitor the monitor this for the safety
of that region you also need to remember
that outbreaks that occur also do a lot
to the healthcare infrastructure in
these countries for instance people that
have complications from other diseases
such as malaria or pregnant women that
may have complicated deliveries all of
those things are hampered when the
health care workers are a being forced
to folk not forced but focus on caring
for patients with this disease and also
encouraging behavior that will not
transmit the disease but also some of
those health care workers are dying and
that is a big concern in these areas we
know that in the 2014 West African
outbreak there may have been almost a
thousand healthcare workers that died
trying to care for patients that
severely disrupts the healthcare
infrastructure in countries one of the
things that we did learn in 2014
outbreak was that to deploy therapeutics
for Ebola as soon as we possibly can
this is something that we were not very
good at in the West African outbreak for
many reasons some of the reasons include
the fact that there are no really
efficacious treatments that are known or
or Ebola virus disease and so we needed
to study some of those in a prospective
way and that started late in the
outbreak in 2016 to try to show of zmapp
was an efficacious therapy during this
outbreak in the Democratic Republic of
the Congo there have been four medical
countermeasures that have been deployed
there's been the map which we many have
heard about from the previous outbreak
that has a combination of three
antibodies run des appear which is an
antiviral Monica Monica will antibody
114 from Merck and then never Jenner on
product that's listed below which is
also three monoclonal antibodies the
interesting things about these that you
need to remember is all of these are
actually given I
and so it's it's um both a challenge
that's being overcome in these in these
settings to give these types of
medications to patients but these have
been deployed this was very early in
this outbreak she's been a big change
and improvement from previous outbreak
if you remember reading about the types
of medications that were given during
the 2014 to 2016 outbreak these were
there were many different medication
many of them were in short supply
because they were only given to it we
don't really know if they were
applications this is something though as
a global community we're trying to
improve want to find the type of
therapeutic that will work for this
disease so that we can treat people they
can survive and do well I'm going to
switch a little bit from focusing on the
Democratic Republic of the Congo which
is a very important place right now and
should warrant our continued vigilance
over that outbreak to a domestic unit in
the United States so our unit at Emory
University Hospital is called the
serious communicable diseases unit this
unit was established in 2002 in order to
provide occupational health for CDC
employees its Emory University Hospitals
next door to the Centers for Disease
Control and Prevention here in Atlanta
and we wanted they wanted a civilian
hospital in the vicinity be able to
support their employees who may have an
exposure or it can attract a disease
either in the field or in the laboratory
as I've already said this was the first
civilian Hospital previous hospitals had
been previous units have been in
military hospitals and have been more
for quarantine and not so much for
clinical care our contract with the CDC
to provide this backup is that we will
be available within one hour of
notification and for that purpose we
have nurses physicians and laboratory
ins on call 24 hours a day seven days a
week for any call related occupational
health is when individuals is it
our unit they are pretty underwhelmed
this looks like most hospital rooms
difference is how we behave in this room
and the type of personal protective
equipment or PPE that we wear this is
the clinical laboratory that is down the
hall from this patient care area and the
clinical laboratory serves just the
Ebola unit and us this allows us not to
send any of the blood work or laboratory
work upstairs to our normal laboratories
so that it will feel safe both in the
clinical laboratory the main Clinical
Laboratory in our Hospital but people
also feel safe in this laboratory
because we have protocols against how to
test things in this laboratory we were
very busy during 2014 and in 2016 we
cared for - for patients with Ebola
virus disease active disease the first
patient to ever have Ebola virus disease
was evacuated to our Hospital on August
2nd 2014 we admitted three individuals
for post exposure prophylaxis that
they've had high risk exposures in the
field in West Africa we also took care
of one patient with Lassa fever virus
which is a very different disease but
similar type of virus in our unit we
also because of where we are located we
rolled out 25 individuals for a bola
none of whom had the disease but all of
whom were we have activated to this area
the monitoring we think a lot about
experimental therapies here at Emory
hospital we have done different
experimental therapies for each one of
our patients including the ones that
have high risk exposures and all of
these were just given to one or two
patients mainly due to the supply of the
drug at the time in the United States we
learned a lot during our clinical care
on the bola virus disease before August
2nd 2014 nobody had ever had a patient
with Ebola virus disease in the United
States and it had only been basically
quarantined and studied at best it could
be in very
source limited settings this really did
change when Kent Brantly was evacuated
to Emory hospital he was at a hospital
that did daily labs that had many nurses
assigned to him for the care of him and
we had the ability to do chest x-rays
and other types of intervention should
we need to what we learned was what
Ebola virus is like in a person we
learned that some of the early symptoms
include fevers chills and fatigue
however these people tended to have
persistent fevers for a long time
especially in the beginning we also know
that they turn the corner and have
symptoms worsen around two weeks into
the illness we call this the
gastroenteritis hepatitis phase where
the patients have your diarrhea and
hepatitis depending on how bad this part
of the phase of their disease is it may
lead to death with multi organ damage if
people have a very mild gastroenteritis
hepatitis sort of phase often we can
tell that they're gonna be better and do
fine our third patient was evacuated
very early in his disease and we thought
that because we had had him evacuated so
early from era Leone that we would
easily be able to support him and ensure
that he would do well this was not to be
the case in terms of having a simple
illness he was critically ill in our in
our Ebola unit and he was admitted b5
until after he developed symptoms and he
even received before he made it to Emory
hospital an experimental medication in
the country however his viral load was
astronomically high and so instead of
him receiving supportive care here at
Emory and just having a mild disease you
know it basically needed to support him
through this critical illness on day six
he started to develop severe
gastroenteritis and hepatitis with up to
10 litres of diarrhea a day he then
turned the corner and had multi or multi
organ system
failure including kidney injury and
respiratory distress putting him on a
breathing machine on day nine Hyundai 11
we started him on dialysis and that
Ebola unit
it was another ten days before he could
come off of the ventilator and it was
another almost ten days after that where
his ability to have a conversation and
be oriented to time and place and
improved his kidneys did actually
eventually recover on their own and he
was discharged 40 days after he was
admitted to our hospital and at that
time he was very tired
he had weight loss go on to have hair
loss and he still has some mild
cognitive dysfunction that least for him
it's very smart guy so it's sort of hard
to tell but he has anything but he feels
like he has difficulty with work finding
for this day so what did we do to Emory
to support this patient that was
critically ill and others we actually
have nurses that are one-on-one for the
in the patient through 24 hours a day
and they took shifts going into the room
we eventually were only using critical
care nurses these nurses have a lot of
flexibility and ability to support
patients in many different areas we also
kept everybody out of the room that
could that should not be in the room or
didn't need to be in the room this
limited anybody else getting infected
from the patient you also really focus a
lot on the emotional support for the
patient and the family support of the
patient and we took care of each other
as providers in order to make sure we
were providing the best patient care
kept our selves safe first so that we
could be free to do a good job for our
patient we asked a lot of clinical
questions during this time one of the
questions we had with the amount of
fluid that comes out of a dialysis
machine was is there still a bola virus
disease present we tested this epic
multiple days by PC
and we could not find any longer that
there was a bowl of virus disease though
while this didn't change how we treated
the waste initially I felt like this was
something that needed to be explored
more in the future
treating waste that comes out of a
patient that's liquid waste it's a lot
of chemicals and time and so we're
trying to ask questions about what we
can hear the other thing that we learned
a lot about that had not been really
well described but was more described
during the 2013 and 2016
Ebola virus outbreak in West Africa
because there were so many survivors we
learned that there is a whole a large
list of things that happen to them after
they've basically recovered from Ebola
virus people have joint pains and
arthritis almost 30% of people with
Ebola virus disease at eye disease in
their convalescent or recovery period
people would have neurologic problems in
problems almost all of our four patients
lost their hair initially after they
recovered from this virus but in my mind
I used to think of Ebola as just a
really binary part of people even there
did well or they didn't do well though
they died or they lived
we didn't think a lot of about anything
else however during our experience
caring for these patients learned a lot
about what all of our a bowl of iris
disease those to the body we learned
about viral persistence and
immunologically sequestered organs we
learned that it can be transmitted
through sexual transmission part of the
part of my viral persistence need to be
evaluated because it persists in the
genital tract of men after they have
recovered and we also thought a lot
about people that may have Ebola virus
disease but never go to the hospital how
many people have been exposed but aren't
known that they even have had it
there are many organs in which this
persists after you get better from a
bola virus disease the main ones are
the central nervous system I'm going to
show you some examples of all of these
feminine fluid of men the center of
women and then in the eye this is a
picture of Pauline Cafferty she's a
Scottish nurse that was evacuated to the
Royal Free Hospital in London she did
very well there although she had an
extremely high viral load like our
critically ill patient but she recovered
fully
however nine months after she was
discharged from the hospital in London
she relapsed with the
meningoencephalitis and she also had a
bowl of viruses in her blood again
there's treated again with more
experimental medication at the same time
and was shown to have antibodies that
detect were detected but and no changes
to suggest that the virus have mutated
but this is very concerning this that
basically Ebola could hang out in her
central nervous system and cause her
disease nine monthly Ebola is present in
semen and at our hospital we were the
first people to start collecting semen
in our survivors and having it tested by
the CDC and so you can see here that the
time the days after symptom onset are on
the left and the five male patients that
we had evacuated to the United States
were on the bottom and you can see that
there was some persistence even in our
small group of patients up to 300 days
by nucleic acid now remember the red box
is at the bottom the red kind of
diamonds are where it actually grew in
culture but we don't know if by
detecting this nucleic acid in this even
if it's actually going to be transmitted
to somebody else but we do know that
that's a possibility brought up to that
line which is at about 75 days and sure
enough we had shown in Liberia that
there was molecular evidence because the
similar virus had passed from person to
person and so you can see here there's a
patient s that basically enters it
evolved a treatment unit
and exits in October of 2014 about 155
days later patient P actually basically
gets transmitted to them yes sexual
intercourse Ebola virus disease and they
present seven days later to an Ebola
treatment unit at that time patient s s
even was tested and it was positive
unfortunately the second patient that
acquired it sexually did die from Ebola
virus they tested the patient the
initial patient s again about a month
later and at that time it was a bola
negative but they do know that from
October to March that there was
persistence of positive bola virus
nucleic acid in the city also there is
this very unusual story that I highly
recommend you look at the Journal
article because it is pretty interesting
how this happened and so there was a
mother that was pregnant and acquired
Ebola virus disease usually when this
happens the babies don't make it through
the disease and this did indeed happen
for this woman and her child but the
woman recovered but her baby
perished from Ebola virus disease much
later though maybe six months later the
woman gets pregnant again with a second
child after she's recovered from Ebola
virus disease and at that time her
spouse and your children and trapped a
bola virus disease from her if baby
lives and does just fine however at
least one of her other children actually
dies from a bola virus disease and so it
is thought in this patient that because
of her pregnancy and that the placenta
is a place that can have Ebola
persistence that there may have been
some remnant of placenta from the baby
that pregnant with first-time where the
baby died
that then reactivated at the time of the
second the other place where we have
seen a bola virus disease basically
hideout is in the eye this is our third
patient who I told you about was very
critically ill on on a ventilator and on
dialysis essentially he ended up with
infection of his eye two months after he
recovered for this within in December of
2014 with Ebola virus disease in fact
when we took a little bit of the eye
fluid from his eye it had a higher viral
load in his eye two months after he
recovered then he had had in his blood
during his illness he was treated at the
time with oral fab appear beer and
steroids you can see that his eye
actually changed a different color and
so for a long time because of the viral
infection of his eye he had two
different eye colors his I eventually
got better the other pictures that you
see below the eye involve the ciliary
muscle and the cornea so his cornea
became very ademma tiss and he also
ended up having a ciliary body that
stopped working for a while those eye
pressure became very low and then very
high so it has been known in the past
that there are some eye manifestations
after recovering from a bola virus
disease this description occurred in
1995 but now we know that this is much
larger problem than we even thought
before so at least 30% have some sort of
AI complaint and we know that even up to
20% have actually uveitis or infection
that looks active this is another
schematic of an eye that might be
infected with Ebola and you can see all
of the aspects of the eye that are
affected so the cornea is infected there
becomes an inflammation within the
anterior chamber of the eye and then
there's actually a retinal scarring and
retinal damage that can happen as well
because of this work dr. yeh and dr.
Champa who are on this article began to
because of this work at Emory
so they diagnosed our third patient with
his eye disease they decided to go and
essentially look in West Africa to see
people were safe to undergo cataract
surgery after they had Ebola virus
disease so the way that they went about
this was to actually test the eye fluid
and people that had cataracts that had
recovered from Ebola virus disease
this is actuals fortunate to go with
them this is actually our Ebola
makeshift Ebola virus unit you can see
that is very simple but we sort of made
it in a unidirectional flow in order to
kind of go into the dirty area and they
sort of come out of that area with the
transition don't zone to take off your
personal protective equipment there were
similar protective equipment that we did
at Emory University Hospital the reason
we did this was for comfort
there's not a lot of air conditioning
there and so we wanted to make sure that
we are very comfortable we were unable
to basically have good climate control
and so we essentially use this work use
this personal protective equipment but
we also limited our procedures to only a
few hours a day you can see here
actually taking in fluid from the eye
just a very tiny bit but testing it for
Ebola to make sure it was safe to do
their cataract surgery what we found was
that we had tested them long enough
after Ebola that none of them had an
active a bolivars
in the eye and so it was in deep sleep
to provide this sight restoring cataract
surgery in Sierra Leone we continue to
think about what we learned from a bola
virus disease and we decided we wanted
to look at how we functioned in that
in that Ebola unit to keep ourselves
safe and so we did a few studies to look
at human factors and virus transfer
during doffing of personal protective
equipment we did this along with Georgia
Tech and Georgia State and what was
resulted was this sort of very
complicated looking failure modes effect
analysis so what this looks at is every
step that the healthcare worker is doing
during the doffing or taking off of
their personal protective equipment and
then what we do is we compare this to
whether or not any any surrogate virus
or fake virus it's transmitted on their
hands or inner gloves then we can go
back and see which thing that we
basically may have made an error doing
that would allow us to figure out what
parts of our doffing are taking off a
personal protective equipment was risky
in this way we've given feedback for our
own protocols to be able to do this one
of the ways that we've been also using
all of our knowledge from taking care of
these individuals is we formed with
University of Nebraska and Bellevue New
York Health New York City Health and
Hospitals we formed this partnership
that was funded by the assistant
secretary for preparedness and response
and the Centers for Disease Control and
we called it
Nene Tech the national Ebola training
and education center this is comprised
of 10 regional treatment centers that
all work together to try to put on-site
consultation exercises and drills for
health care system and basically to go
help anybody that needs help with
healthcare preparedness this has been an
incredible experience participating in
this and that we've gone all over the
United States forming partnerships
learning other best practices and
imparting on those the practices that we
did to keep ourselves safe
one of the other questions we had for
our health care workers was to ask did
any of us possibly be exposed and not
really know that we were exposed to
Ebola virus while we were caring for our
poor patients that aren't in that of
Emory hospital so we did a serology
study to see if anybody had basically
been exposed to this but not but had not
developed clinical disease and so you
can see here we tested two different
types of antigens related to Ebola virus
disease on the top you can see that
seven people looked like they might have
a reaction those seven people indeed had
had a vaccine against Ebola virus
disease and should have had a reaction
to this type of antigen on the bottom
you can see another type of antigen from
the Ebola virus and nobody responded to
it so essentially we learned that we did
have good immune response in the
healthcare workers that have been
vaccinated and that nobody and have been
exposed to any sort of even small amount
of Ebola some of the other things that
we learned was that we partnered with
our basic scientists that were on campus
and elsewhere people in the past thought
the Ebola virus really suppressed the
immune system but if you've taken care
of a patient you know that they are not
so their immune system is not suppressed
it's really trying to fight back and
that causes a lot of their sepsis and
organ damage during this time so we
learned that a bola virus infected
dendritic cells were impaired in their
ability to produce cytokines we also
learned that macrophages also exhibit
were infected we learned that Ebola
virus encodes proteins that interfere
with the immune response and that
clinical observations had to develop
some of these other things but what we
learned so those are sort of the things
that had been previously thought to
happen however what we learned was that
everything was enhanced so we saw plasma
blast activating cd4 cells activate to
see to eight T cells
and
this was all occurring as the viral load
was high but even after the viral load
was going down you can see that the
immune response was really trying to
work to try to contain the virus during
the outbreak of 2013 and 2016 we also
learned that the VSV vaccine was
definitely one of the strategies to help
prevent infection and those people that
are that were basically exposed to
people that have developed Ebola virus
disease I'm happy to say that this
vaccine has been given in over 50
thousand people in the area of the
Democratic Republic of the Congo to try
to mitigate any sort of transmission
even other countries are starting to
vaccinate people along the border with
the democratic-republican after we had
cared with our patients with Ebola virus
disease we also had an admission in
March of 2016 of an evacuated missionary
nurse who had contracted Lhasa in a
place that have not known that Lassa
fever existed so we helped identify I'm
using the CDC in a German scientific
biology group that we had had actually
had a patient that had a new novel
strain that had not been known from Toba
so again our goal has always been to
sort of contribute to the scientific and
clinical literature of these patients
with special pathogens so where are we
in 2018 and where are we in 2019 we are
definitely more internationally more
attentive to the regional outbreaks I
will tell you that I'd not I don't
follow in the past I'd not follow to
bolivars
outbreaks day by day we know that has
how to deploy therapeutics much sooner
we also are trying to study these
therapeutics so that we can actually be
able to recommend a therapeutic in the
future for other patients we also have
an awareness and a monitoring plan for
people that have made
by our persistence and these immune
privilege sites such as the ones I
discussed such as the semen and seminal
organs of men Ascenta and the eye
disease as well as the central nervous
system and we know that vaccination is
going to be a big promise and a big
aspect of future outbreaks as is in the
current effort so in every hospital we
have a huge team that supports the work
that we're doing both when were
activated and when we're not activated
and so I can't thank them enough we
could not do it without everybody
working together that's been one benefit
if we could say there's a benefit of
taking care of these patients in our
Hospital was that we became a much more
integrated interprofessional team to
deal with crisis situations we have
funding for the work that we're doing
from the Centers for Disease Control
from the assistant secretary of
preparedness and response and from NIOSH
at this time I'll take any questions and
I thank you for your attention and thank
you dr. Kraft for that informative
presentation I'd like to also thank lab
roots for making today's educational
webcast possible as a final reminder dr.
Kraft will follow up with any questions
you've submitted via email that's all
for now thank you for joining us we will
see you next time bye bye